and I have made a Christmas there we saw
you celebrating 10 years of Miranda
which must I mean you know just on a
personal level you must fit must give
you a kind of a warm feeling that kind
of like I did this thing yeah it was
sort of a mixture of initially really
embarrassing thinking am I allowed to
celebrate you know sort of hosting a
show it's celebrating myself there was
that initial such a British oh this is a
bit awkward and then I just thought you
know it the show did really well and I'm
allowed to celebrate it would be proud
of it and so to celebrate that and then
what the show's meant to people that was
the biggest surprise because I guess at
the time you're just busy writing jokes
you just wanted to be funny but actually
in hindsight that show had a sort of
message yeah I think suddenly realizing
I mean after the sort of second series
when I started getting letters from
particularly teenage girls or women in
their twenties sort of saying are you
really happy with that with my anxiety
or haven't we felt I could accept myself
you know if Miranda I can accept
yourself and I can you know I'm allowed
to be tall I'm allowed to eat I'm
allowed to be big and loud and
celebrating female friendship and not
needing romance and all that sort of
self-acceptance and self compassion and
I started thinking wow I'm writing
something much more with a heavier
subtext and I thought and obviously I
think subconsciously there was obviously
a lot more going into the writing that I
realized so it was kind of cool to to
acknowledge that
[Music]
you